fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby rock and roll one thing
about me when you have green shoes on
like that I want to stick my dick right
in your [__] I know isn't that crazy
yeah yeah I know
yes
the green I didn't know yeah I didn't
know no I want the people to see the way
you treat me I did not no that's the we
heard of course sexual harassment you're
looking at HR buddy [__] dude I just got
excited about it after I wear green
you're allowed to stick your wiener I
just I I just want to say something
outrageous because I saw the green yeah
you ever get a surge of energy and
you're like I have a surge of energy and
I want to say something [__]
ridiculous sure and I just said
something ridiculous but you're also
ingrained yours is like a trash green
this was a this was a sort of this
screen just kind of happened it's Oscar
the Grouch green well Brian decided that
he wasn't going to pay retail I go on
Amazon now and I buy sweaters
well I just I buy sweatshirts sweaters
because I can buy them for 34.
134. will you pay for it right what
brand is Calvin Klein
Calvin Brian it's Calvin Ryan Calvin
Ryan
it's Calvin Ryan and uh Oscar the Grouch
green but let's be honest it's like when
I said to you Brandon should I use way I
slit or wait wait wait it doesn't matter
doesn't matter though right and also
Brian should I wear a Versace sweater or
a should I wear Calvin plan it doesn't
matter don't wear Versace whatever it is
56 year old Brian yeah it my life is
gonna be different if I wear a 600
sweater or
yeah I wear it like super comfy wide toe
shoes I'm becoming dad guy yeah I get it
yeah sometimes that other stuff's not
important yeah now I stopped eating
you'll appreciate it stopped eating
wheat a while back because because uh I
found I had an allergy did you do that
when you that's all right yes yeah then
I I just had two pieces of pizza from
Jelena hard to say no to that right then
that's why Daddy was late let's be
honest and I accept that that's a great
reason to be late I'm with you not about
it I'd be late for that yeah I'm not mad
I can't get money well I gave myself a
half hour but then that rock half hour
to get from Venice to here that's
aggressive and it's aggressive than the
rock thing yeah giant rocks Brian told
me he was late because there's a rock on
Malibu chicken rocks fell down instead
of giant rock that didn't scare me if I
take that route every time I'm out of
the candy those rocks are real those
giant Bowlers but here here's the thing
if that rock falls on top of your car
it's that's the big mango it's your time
you're done
it's your time that'd be terrible you
can't worry about that
no well it's like be terrible it's not
that we'll be terrible if the rock fell
right on just your legs oh and then the
top Stone and it scraped this part of
your face it's like when people try to
end their life and they shoot themselves
in the face and then they survive yeah
doctor they wake up he's like good news
you're alive you hate yourself before
well now look in the mirror you're
missing half your head yes so things
were bad before well I I was next to a
guy when I had my my hernia surgery he
had his chest open up open heart surgery
doctor I swear to God he comes rolling
over and you're standing up in the thing
and he's like ah
I'm in pain but I I don't hey I was in
pain too you're a stop it right now you
[__] yours was hernia yeah I know but
that's a noise okay it's still a noisy I
don't yell out like that the doctor goes
I got good news no cancer
and he goes I don't care make the pain
stop miserable what do you have done
what they have to do to open up his chat
I saw it right there
yeah he helped sore he must yeah you're
not you're not you're not okay for about
nine months after that Jesus Christ yeah
you ain't doing much you ain't gesturing
with your with your arms open you ain't
doing ballet you ain't doing no you
ain't doing nothing
yeah now my father plays golf when he's
not playing golf
the man is as sedentary as it gets my
mother's like can you walk somewhere he
goes no let's just sit and read those
new newspapers old school he reads he
takes Italian lessons don't ask me why
doesn't even like Italian
uh and then he um and then he watches
documentaries on fish big cats oh okay
that's old that's that's old [__] that's
Daddy's [__] yeah I get it yeah plays
guitar
not good just recently picked up yeah
not not not not a musician yeah doesn't
have the fingers for it well I don't
even care about it my dad got into the
Bongos
hold on
hold on all the instruments he's all
dinked your dad is a bit of a closet
hippie there's something in him I don't
know what that is and the Bongos took
lessons on it but don't yeah the banjos
bongos
you know what I think you know what I
think about it has to be the easiest one
to play around you want to know a secret
I haven't told anyone I know that none
of you guys listening will tell anybody
I after watching Channing Tatum my
boyfriend in Magic Mike dancing lessons
I I watched him do that and I secretly I
log away I go I'm gonna learn how to do
that wow I'm 56. but why that's a good
question you know you were caught in the
moment it's like whenever you come back
from a story you have an answer if
you're like I'm moving to Nashville like
you're out of your mind I got too much
of it too much I you watch tentative
YouTube I youtubed a little tutorial and
I went have you tried a lot I was like
oh no this is a lot and also even if I
could dance that way at 56 don't uh no
if you dance like him you want me to
take his I would sell for you if you're
on Tick Tock and [__] doing that you do
it dude [__] you know what you might be
able to escape an amazing idea for my
social media Journey there you go I'm
going to document and I will apologize
right now for this I'm going to document
my path as a dancer did you well did you
ever see sagura train for like weeks to
do a dance video of bird he danced
really well well they it's put a it's a
big production put like a [__] ton of
money got a legit choreographer like to
pay like legit Dancing Yeah
let me just stab bird at the end
so stupid
that was really good actually and he had
they had special effects so he looked
really heavy
so good
you know I can't stop laughing at that
Louis CK bit you sent me I showed Delia
we were laughing so hard so hard we me
and Delirious uh taping yesterday I go
do y'all see this bit and he's like oh
my God I mean I I the way she runs away
from him she goes oh my God God it's not
no it wasn't me I swear it presses the
bunions
he's all God damn just woke up I gotta
watch that show again Lucy okay I've
never watched it I saw that Jay loves it
gotta watch Jason a bunch of it so
[__] funny so funny so funny
um well have you watched anything uh
cool I'm into
um your honor
what's that yeah see it's a big show
people told me to watch it before your
honor so it's this judge that that dude
uh Brian Cranston for Breaking Bad he's
a judge his son wow in the first episode
his son is reaching for a cell phone and
and kills a young man on a motorcycle
that young man on the motorcycle who
died he's the son of the top mob boss in
all of New Orleans oh Jesus so the sun
leaves the scene comes back tells the
dad and Dad's like what the [__] so dad
was going to turn him in but he's like
oh you're gonna go away I mean for life
I can't lose my son but he's like a
stand-up judge like the top judge of New
Orleans so he has to cover it it gets
it's so stressful it's so good I'm
always it's so good dude so good all
over that they're on season two now I'm
halfway through season one I don't get
another season two but we'll figure it
out oh I'm so all over there yeah it's
fantastic your honor your honor you you
you you that that's every man can
understand like your son is everything
thank you
100 well that goes to the
John Gotti thing
you know that story which one when John
Gotti was a captain
somebody killed the Sun the guy ran a
son over oh yeah yeah yeah and I guess
he killed that guy yeah I guess the they
were throwing a party next door no not
at all so is his young son he was six or
seven he was on his bike out front of
their house and the and the kid it was
actually the kid mom's fault it was in
the driver's fault right he because the
cops came and he didn't get arrested but
the kid darted off into the street
without looking got hit by the car died
yeah and then like time goes by and that
guy was scared he's about to move he put
his house on sale on the street because
it's John Gotti's [__] son he killed
on accident and then something happened
where he came over to the house and or
they shared a backyard and the wife was
like yelling at him yelling at him and
told John like you know you got to do
something he's like yeah yeah you got it
so then he went to Florida supposedly
but had his guys apprehend him and
according to Sammy the bull he they
tortured this guy they put him in the
basement of the house and torched them
for weeks before cutting them up into
like a million pieces
but also you ran over John got his kid
get out of there right away it was a
backyard neighbor crime family and
little boss John Gotti
Jesus he had killed his 12 year old son
yeah there it goes was attacked with a
baseball bat by Victoria Gotti
the mom
ah and then he went he went over to
apologize and she attacked him with a
bat
man
is that terrible he was shoved into a
van by several men in the other place
for his business
beaten with a baseball bat shot he's
widely assumed you think to have ordered
the murder despite the fact his family
depart for a Florida vacation three days
before
that's convenient when questioned by two
detectives yeah
man then when the cops ask God about he
goes I'm not sorry the guy's missing I
wouldn't be sorry if the guy turned up
dead
uh what's it was previously prosecuted
believed Farmers remains were stuffed in
a barrel of concrete and tossed over
sheep's heads bay Pier but Brooklyn
Federal court papers filed by federal
prosecutors the week of January 5th on
nine contain allegations that mob Hitman
Charles killed Farva and disposed of his
body in acid
yeah well either way but yeah you killed
John Gotti's son is that that's what how
this is
yeah because his son dies in this guy
and the boss is Gangster man Jesus
stressful
yeah there's so many twists and turns in
this show it's so good dude yeah oh man
Brennan let's take a break first of all
if you like comedy this weekend in New
York City Marshall Hometown selling out
New York City get your tickets tickets
that Manhattan yes
so can you get some tickets come on do
it and then you're back to New York back
in New York Levity Live I'm in Nyack
West Nyack New York March 16th to the
18th but you know that's what I had to
say I know you're in Oklahoma and my
beak is gonna be wet oh [__] in Oklahoma
City this Thursday Friday Saturday
Oklahoma City breaks down Comedy Club my
favorite venues in all the land Oklahoma
city is this truck and Thursday Friday
Saturday Tacoma Washington March 23rd
through 25th then Atlanta Spokane and La
Jolla comic store just want to sale June
2nd through the 4th and then Europe it's
happened in June 15th through was that
June 25th Glasgow Manchester London
Cardiff Dublin Belfast I'm all over
Europe get your tickets now at
thickboy.com also fight companion March
18th Joe Rogan and friends I'll be there
in Austin make sure you tune in JRE on
YouTube live and it goes to Spotify
listen Oklahoma City let's see this
weekend you guys sometimes you know
Brian this show is sponsored by better
help I better help yeah you know what I
better help is good because you need
somebody who's a professional sometimes
to talk to if you're a guy and you know
it's your friends don't know how to help
you man guys like guy you'll get over it
but the fact of the matter is your
mental health is real man and sometimes
you really do need somebody to talk to
I've been there I've been there and
you're one of my you're my best friend I
don't I don't call you and talk to you
don't call me and talk to me how are you
going to help me you think armbar kills
people listen better help connect you
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are all right I've
benefited from therapy feel free Brian
to talk about how strength because you
can be you can be paired up with a
licensed professional in under 48 hours
and you're not in a waiting room it's a
lot cheaper they're professionals so
they help you navigate whatever crazy
anxiety you have or stress you have
they're going to help you is an
outsider's perspective but it's a
professional and all you gotta do is
fill out a brief questionnaire so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
it a try give better help a freaking try
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com fighter today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash fighter I need I need
better focus and memory and I don't know
what to do I'm making coffee no you need
Alpha Brain if at your level you need
the regular Alpha Brain they've sold
over a million bottles it's the best
thing Alpha Brain Black yes that's what
Daddy uses right and when I'm on stage
in Oklahoma City this Thursday Friday
Saturday I will be loaded to the guild
so Alpha Brain Black Label will help me
on my March 11th show this weekend no
guarantees New York City
I think it will do better yes what about
what about like krill oil what about
like what about the Alpha Brain shot you
want to take a little Focus shot but
boom and next thing you know you're
you're Jeff Bezos it's a nootropic it's
a nootropic yep they sold over a million
bottles money back guarantee if you
don't like it the reason that it works
the reason I like on it obviously an
alpha brain is because they've done
double blinds
placebo-controlled double lines and
Alpha Brain Black Label is the highly
concentrated Alpha Brain it's the best
nootropic I've ever tried they have it
all streaming fitness workout gear but
the Alpha Brain is what they're running
the ship that's their Flagship Alpha
Brain Black Label get you some go to
onit.com
f-a-t-k that's on it.com f-a-t-k you
save ten percent off every Alpha Brain
those instant shots the instant packs
the focus shots I mean the Black Label
the regular Alpha Brain try it all out
audit.com f-a-t-k all right and you save
temps off everything let's go back to
the program
what shows right now are the last of us
which is fantastic this last episode it
was just okay this last one last of us I
see I I don't I don't get where people
like the one before that were in the
arcadians the girl and her friend it's
like a lesbian relationship they tell
their backstory That's How The Show Goes
he goes two steps forward one step back
to tell the backstory two steps forward
one step back but uh maybe just again
I'm getting older I don't need all the
zombie action and gun yeah like I like a
story I like the story it's like I
watched uh the whale with uh Brendan
Frazier he's gonna win the Oscar on
Sunday for the whale
there's no action
nobody gets beat up nobody gets shot
there's no it's just a good real story
what am I looking for in my porn
no stories [__] real stories
um but like you got done watch Chris
Rock special I still I saw some of it
yeah
but it's funny right how people like uh
who allies with uh me Eric Griffin and
Chris went to lunch yesterday and uh
Chris is like yeah I heard it's getting
bad reviews I said Chris where what
review did you see because he goes
against the woke canceled culture and
all that stuff so of course the left
which is the main mainstream media are
getting a [__] on it they're gonna no
this is terrible this is terrible any
real normal person that's not I loved it
with some agenda I thought it was great
inspiring it made me start it actually
got me to start writing I was I was
writing I wrote a bunch of great stuff
also comedy's all relative right it's
all perspective so if if you're awoke or
whatever that pisses off you're gonna
hate the whole thing he tells the truth
it makes everybody uncomfortable what's
the same thing with Dave Chappelle
special right it's what they I didn't
think it was but they called it
anti-trans you watch it hilarious
anti-trans so how many like people like
his last specials just aren't as good as
like yeah they are yeah he just said
something that struck a you know
according
a pro-trans not between 98 of the entire
United States was anybody offended and
the outrage the small two percent
they're all fake yeah I don't believe I
I don't think they're fake I think
they're they're real people they're just
loud as [__] I think the trans activists
are fake I don't buy it I don't no I
just saw there might be some there might
be some trans people who but for the
most part the people that are the people
fight for it aren't even trans they
don't even know trans what I mean like
the guy who uh I don't know well their
agendas like they're they're not
actually doing anything for Trans
who is the uh
the trans quote-unquote trans sort of uh
person who the the guy who was a
showrunner for a TV show and said sorry
Netflix I'm done it was a TV show and he
kind of like bailed and I guess he he
was posting pictures of him in a bikini
but he's a full-grown I don't know what
I'm talking about
dear wife leaves Netflix after Dave yeah
there you go oh that dude
yeah okay Jeremiah
that's somebody who just jumped on the
bandwagon as far as I'm concerned that's
what it looked like
that's her quote
uh after the spell I can't do this
anymore I won't work for Netflix again
as long as they keep promoting and
profiting from dangerous transfer all
the content oh
yeah well that's great enjoy that too
bad what are we gonna do without your
but here's but here's my thing all good
all good yes you don't like whatever
Direction Netflix is going you leave
that's your right exactly right yeah
it's all good I'm not mad at her yeah if
you're if that's with anything if you
don't like it you know you no one's
forcing you to sit down and watch Dave
Chappelle's content yeah I I I
okay just looking
all right
wait let me see what that caption says
the one that was on that is just I don't
think I've ever loved underwear as much
as I love
[Music]
um
oh okay
literally losing a girl
what is it what are you losing literally
losing it like okay
literally losing it I'll tell you what's
not where is she is this Jaclyn Moore
losing it or is this person no there's
it's kind of like a compliment no
Jacqueline hasn't lost it yet that's
still there
okay right
yeah anyway yeah it's been good for her
for doing what she thought was right you
know sure do your thing yeah that's with
anything you don't you know if you don't
whatever you don't like Brian Collins
comedy you don't like Chrisley you don't
like Theo just leave you know what I'm
saying like no one's forced to buy
tickets to the show yeah
it's so strange to me
oh man dear white people lost their
[__] children I'm gonna freak out man
that's one of my favorite shows
I'm sure that shows Pro white ah dear
white people that can't be good hard
pass yeah that's why I like Netflix that
doesn't come up and suggest it they know
what's up they know what daddy's gonna
like it's all serial killers you oh yeah
all serial kills the algorithm yeah
about Sam tripley is making a shirt that
says your algorithm is lying too it's so
true because you'll be on YouTube and
I'll look up something that's like
conservative or whatever and all I get
is just bombarded with with liberals
getting creamed by conservatives I'm
like this is not the real world can I
get a balance please
yeah it's great if you look at Ben
Shapiro or you look up one of our Jordan
Peterson you're going to get every other
conservative yeah you might like this
you're not going to get his page you're
gonna get all the negative and then if
you keep scrolling on like the seventh
page you get his [__] yeah think how
much content he puts out a lot both of
them yeah Crowder Shapiro all of it it's
just you know left owns YouTube so it's
just gonna bombard you with all that
[__] but they say they left on his
YouTube but I'm saying is that if you
you you can if you're kind of right wing
you're gonna get a lot of right wing
stuff you're left wing you're gonna let
a lot of left swing the algorithm is
interesting because it'll tend to push
you toward what you want to see that's
anything yeah but what else should do
push you too because you would think if
if YouTube was something meaning left
they would if you you think of YouTube
is leaning left you'd think that they
would send you only left-wing stuff but
actually they they double down on
whatever you're looking at so if you're
looking at it really because they
suppress certain things that doesn't
push the agenda so that's where they
lean left because certain things will
suppress a certain alpha male LP
characters they're going to suppress
their views well my my uh so your word
doesn't get out there as much I see well
my Instagram thing was funny because my
Instagram thing was
I would uh look at working out things
boxing things MMA things and chicks with
dicks the problem is that they were not
chicks not chips and dicks keep going
I'm not I filled that info but there
were there are very pretty girls on
Instagram who get pop-up they just do
whatever they're just sitting there and
nothing in there I don't know that's
Instagram going you might like this
right and then you watch it and then you
might thumb through and then there's
another girl now here's the problem I
had people working on my social media
they had access to my Instagram
and I at one point I looked at my
Instagram and it there were a lot of
suggestions in my search bar of just
girls
and tits yeah we're like hey guys like
what are you clicking all right yeah and
that's clearly what I was clicking on
you know I was like oh well nothing to
see here creepy old man well sometimes
there's those older actors that last one
was Samuel Jackson he was clicking on
porn but there's some that have like
like some other porn you know like the
dicey porn and they like it and they
were oh everyone can see their stuff oh
yeah but they'll like like you know
chicks with dicks like stuff you like
yeah yeah a guy's [__] on the mouth on
another guy's [__] [__] and [__] this I
thought I was I was all I did was to put
in college guys whoa wow this is amazing
cocked on [__] where are they gonna put
it what is this and you I'm like what
yeah I gotta figure this out this is a
weird type in sexy man I meant sexy
girls the algorithm goes hey we know
what you like it's like no no it's not
like dude I can explain yeah I know
Sam's gay he thinks I is full of [__]
yeah the algorithm gives me some fire
like I was just watching last night
Netflix recommended this new documentary
on uh it's in France about the most uh
kind of successful successful successful
serial killer in France oh man you're so
it's all subtitles and I watched it so
it was I fell asleep some this guy is
killing teenage girls and raping them
like sadistic as [__] but the wife was
like in on it you get the girls in the
car the wife I think got off but they
interviewed the wife but the guy's a
real piece of [__] but you see him I'm
like how could these teenage girls not
fight off this old fragile [__] idiot
you know well and that's how you got
caught one girl did get away is it Dr
Harold Shipman
uh no man okay [__] that's in France
no you said the most well bro it's in
France I didn't hear the prince Ecuador
any of those names ring a bell uh it's
at Michael this one Michelle Fortner
it's Michelle Fernandez
I don't know how fit that's him though
that guy that guy the guy looks like
falchi oh man
take on what him being a piece of [__]
uh come at me bro man this guy is as
what would he do kidnap the girls 10
girls and killed him raped him uh eight
eight yeah God what a [__]
and he's in prison like they need to
bring back that uh
where they cut off your head thing guys
at age 79 but they should like [__]
yeah just [__] killing him and his
wife his wife is handsome yeah she was
involved
what a scumbag man
but they're saying she was just like a
pushover like he'd be gone for like
eight days and she wouldn't ask any
questions or nothing
but then when they investigate his house
went into the house they get a search
warrant and they found like the little
girl's clothing
guns yeah horrible horrible yeah I don't
like that [__] yeah I fall asleep to it
I have problems well there's this morbid
curiosity
Rogan talks about he'll he'll watch
anything once
you know what I mean horse dick you know
in somebody's butt oh yeah
I'm not like that I don't watch
beheadings none of that [__] the
beheadings I can't do the shootings at
Worldstar check out because it's kind of
a grainy uh it's not very clear I can
deal with that yeah the fights I can
deal with you know the problem with
fights now is like when we were kids
we'd fight
nobody got knocked out you know we got
[__] up now they go until somebody
gets knocked out and nobody breaks up
because everyone's on their phones it's
a real issue weird because they want to
put it on their social media so no one
even it's your friends they're not
stopping the fight and these kids go
because they know what's going to go
viral as a knockout so they go to
somebody gets [__] concussed okay God
I never got concussed as a kid fighting
did you ever never you'd like to have
your scramble or whatever and little
fisticuff and then my friendship kids
were kids and he said down in San Diego
and uh he well he's a lawyer in general
and he says the the
the clients he has you know the fights
now people are training so he'll have to
defend the guy for yeah he'll defend a
guy for breaking popping someone that
goes elbow or knocking them out really
badly it's like these guys are all like
training in Jiu Jitsu they're training
they're boxing they're doing MMA and the
the injuries are way worse he said he's
like I'm dealing with [__] crazy
defend these guys I'm like you're a
brown Belden Jiu Jitsu and did you know
that you were you know you broke his
[__] shoulder as well brown belt he
definitely knows what he's doing yeah
not good not good yeah they're weird
because back in the day kids would stop
the fight because they didn't want to
see it now they're too busy recording it
because they want to get followers
they're like scares me man it's not good
I guess all parents have always said
that but let's see now's the word but
violence now's the worst time for sure
no no no violence uh according to
Stephen Pinker the violent people are
dying of violent death is the lowest
it's ever been in history
by far yeah we're do we we're just more
people forget we're more prone to see it
because people forget it in bars he's in
the 70s and 80s and 90s
non-stop but we didn't hear about it
because there weren't phones and you'd
have so much negativity and and and in
the during in the west you know in the
1800s and early 1900s uh people got shot
and stabbed right and beaten up like and
killed all the time if you talk to Jimmy
Burke's uncle and his dad what Brooklyn
was like when they were growing up in
the 40s and 50s was The Purge
yeah yeah totally different yeah
America's supposed to be the safest I've
ever been but if you look at the news or
your social media you're terrified yeah
I have so much anxiety especially I have
kids it's [__] terrifying when when
uh Jimmy Jimmy's uh Jimmy Burke is in
there and his father is a great guy his
father said watch the news tonight Jimmy
goes about what he was just watch the
news it's back when there was news you
know
and uh
Robert Burke uh Robert Burke um
of Brooklyn New York Chase is down
gunman tackles him holds him until the
cops come
so he owns a bar and a guy comes in
well-dressed guy comes in and I guess
starts stealing the tips
they catch him these are Irish guys and
tigers catch them the bar was full of
other cops or [__] Jesus Christ Mafia
it's a bad idea thing
there he goes
give us some money back and the guy goes
I didn't take any money
Bob goes it's an easy way to do this
there's a hard way to do this
give us the money back and the guy goes
are you ready
Bob goes am I what he goes oh you ready
Bob goes yeah I'm Ready the guy pulls
out a gun and shoots at him twice and
misses they're close but Jesus
Runs Out starts running down the street
bob goes in my bar this [__]
comes running after him guy turns back
around and shoots the Bob again misses
him
it's all in the news yeah on the news
tackles them holds them down the ground
if you knew Jimmy's dad you'd know he
was a nut you'd be playing basketball
with him he's 70 years old he has the
worst shot in the world he'd get in a
fist fight yeah he's the worst yeah I
mean yeah but I also think that was back
when you didn't think much you it was
like back then you didn't see worlds
over people getting shot it was like
there was something different about it
it was like yeah like the guy's got a
3080 shooting let's get him yeah they're
coming to get him now you assume
everybody has a gun yeah yeah it was a
different time I don't know it's a weird
thing if you if you are very familiar
with how what a gun can do to you like
if you're a tip of the spear Soldier or
something like that and you had a lot of
experience you're gonna be way more
cautious around guns if you've not
around guns yeah you might ask it looks
like something in the movies it's not as
yeah I was talking to this young kid the
other day and he said some guy cut him
off he got out and was like pull over
[__] and the guy pulled out a
gun was like call me a [__] again who's
the the [__] oh yeah he's like I'm a
[__] I'm gonna get back in my car he's
like you damn Reagan by your car and I
told him I said how in the [__] why
would you assume that you would I assume
everybody I piss off on the road how's
it going me too I don't entertain it I'm
like I'm not willing to die over now
this guy cut me off I don't give a [__]
press somewhere did you see that thing
on [__] it was awful but it was on uh
the guy was obviously newest Jiu Jitsu
this guy this this guy guy takes your
shirt off rough guy look it's in the
streets yeah it's a video it was it was
actually I think it was in a parking lot
and the closed caption camera car okay
the guy comes up picks him up kind of by
under the arms and just kind of throws
him in the air throws me or pushes him
then comes back
and this guy just takes his arm and does
a judo trip
and puts him in a beautiful arm bar okay
so now the guy's in an arm bar like this
he's like in an arm bar and you see him
just reach in and he just comes up and
goes boom well the knife
stabs in like five times in the face
right in the chest and the guy's like
that yeah and then he gets in his face
like he's like Mom can I act like that
and then he just walks away Jesus Christ
it's like that's that Jiu Jitsu is
awesome awesome unless they have a knife
unless they have a gun God if you're
gonna fight somebody you better figure
out like how to control their their
assume they have something and end it
and keep keep hitting them you know what
I'm saying though but also once you feel
like a straight [__] if you're on a
fight you have to use a gun or knife no
if the guy's getting the best of you
this guy is getting an arm bar and he's
like oh well clearly he can fight I
can't let me grab this knife and kill
him you gotta assume then you come home
and your buddies like what happened to
come in armor would you I took my knife
out like are you such a well this guy is
a criminal this guy clearly had done
that before
a guy who's who's a fighter and a
criminal and a gang guy yeah whatever he
was yeah he clearly he's not afraid of
jail he's been in jail you could see the
tattoos his body you were like back
that's a jailhouse body yeah there you
can see that you can see and you'd pick
up on her right away and it's like
you're you're fighting a dude who's very
very comfortable with like he's not a
fighter he's gonna kill you very
different
and just stabbed him yeah I just assume
everyone has a gun
yeah
yeah best way to live life
really I think so you just assume that
the ultimate worse you know how to [__]
with it a good idea would be to carry a
gun yourself in case which I do yeah
yeah but again I'm not gonna pull it out
no I'm have it nearby because if he has
one hopefully I have one but if he
doesn't Gamo I carry nunchucks and
throwing stars
yeah good luck dodging gas poison gas
yeah
you know I used to have none
I would take two broomsticks and I take
a nylon rope and I just swing the [__]
at him yeah I love him and I said to my
father I wanted to walk to uh I don't
know where my father said you're not
gonna walk there I go I have numb chucks
I was a kid and he goes he goes your
nunchucks Are Not Gonna Save you if a
guy comes at you and I said yes they
will I you know me I'm like oh yes they
will you're like excuse me my father
said you think so I said yeah he goes go
ahead and try to hit me you swing him so
he's a little guy starts ringing me he
just literally just charged me and
grabbed me I was like ah [__]
then one time then one time we're we're
in a we're in Africa we're in Kenya and
we were eating at this thing and there
was a wall and then there were these
signs that say do not go down to the
riverbed
right there you can see the big
crocodiles they were right there
they were literally on the bank you know
and I remember I said you know
I said like if somebody got bit by a
crocodile I would I would go down there
and I would stab it right here my father
I'd be mad my father goes no you
wouldn't you wouldn't do [__] no you
wouldn't do that with the Dinosaurs
staring hard that's what you would do I
was like Jesus Christ and why be so I
was so embarrassed you could steering
everyone his voice got really no you
would you would sit there and stare in
horror and do nothing and that's what
you would do other people around Jesus
yes it's like a nice afternoon I was
like no I'm trying to impress that girl
over there you know what you're doing
right now that's the same thing I did in
the North Woods I saw a bobcat and there
was a girl I really liked and I said I'd
kill a bobcat and uh and she goes you
would and I go stab it you just take it
and you let it bite you yeah you stab it
my father no you wouldn't no [__]
killing me hey [__] blocks hey I'm
[__] eight [__] clearly I'm
not gonna establish seriously Bobcat man
I'm in love with that girl yeah I'm
trying to get my dick sucked damn it
I hate reality checks Oh no you're a bit
of a reality check with that this is
good well I think I could fight him
would you yeah oh you wouldn't what
would you do very cool well check this
out
what do you got Jen
when Shane Carlin picked me up and
squeeze me right
yeah I mean I don't need to be there but
I was there it was in Vegas the first
time I met you yeah and he picked me up
and he started squeezing me oh uh Nate
markers and I go I go and I I heard him
go he goes That's 40 and I and I tapped
yeah and I said to Nate could he do that
to you and he goes if I let him he might
be able to yeah
weird would you but is it yeah a grown
man squeezing you not even doing it not
doing a submission just squeezing your
body yeah that's a little that's that's
ridiculous you live in reality that I
don't think you could do that to me yeah
I've done that to you
have I showed you a picture today of how
I used to sell merch just my girl's ass
with the fight and the kid sweatshirt on
it these days 10 11 years ago
I remember one time we were we were
shooting uh our sketch show and you were
taking a nap you were all low energy and
I just [__] threw you in a head and
arm head like and sat my [__] butt
out and I was like here you go how about
now and you started giggling and you
were like and you peeled my face
[Music]
wait can I share a quick story yeah so
street fighting uh
I got not a real fight but then I got
approached by a guy he thought I was a
gang um gang member whatever
was no no I'm like but I was like you
know I was always kind of like if they
approached me that I'm always like you
know barking back all right so what the
[__] and then he pulled out
a knife like this long from his
waistband like Crocodile Dundee like and
we're in the mall so I'm like what the
hell yeah so I just backed up like what
I go fight like a man So eventually you
know security came because he had a
[__] knife yeah so I told my dad
about it I told my dad I'm like what do
I do when someone pulls out he goes you
have a belt right I go yeah he goes just
take off the belt wrap it around your
hand and you have this much more
distance if you smack him in the face he
didn't even think twice about like no
don't fight he's just like do you have a
belt that's Korean that's correct my dad
here's what I say it's man here's what I
say run as fast as you can as soon as I
saw I was erection I felt the knife
going through I literally felt like
burning in my stomach when I saw the
knife I'm like oh yeah yeah what's the
point like and why are you fighting why
were you guys gonna fight literally he
just said where you from
Imagine you not being on this earth
right now
over a guy going where are you from
that's what happens though but how
stupid oh it's so stupid on Worldstar
see you know somebody else bumped into
another guy's girl and he goes get your
[__] you gotta go excuse me it's like
so then let's say that's your brother
how'd your brother die but this guy and
said get your [__] shot him in the face
God damn it's like what yeah yeah none
of Christmas lost his life because the
guy asked where he's from where he's
from in front of him Mrs Fields in the
mall
yeah that's sad that's a bad situation
yeah that's not good it's just like the
way my dad my dad's insane huh yeah I
think maybe because all the years of
fighting I know how bad it can get so in
my head if ever I'm in the situation I
go through everything every it's like
Spider-Man like well you know to that
guy's point like Jiu Jitsu you put
something in an arm bar you just can see
what Jiu Jitsu can do you can kill
somebody with Jiu Jitsu it's not with an
arm bar yeah but but I bet you that guy
probably got off if he has a good lawyer
lawyers like he had him in an arm bar
he's breaking his arm and he stabbed him
you know but it's not a life or death
situation I bet he didn't you could you
could make the argument though I don't
know no you can't yeah he's going to
jail hey Brian you can't kill somebody
from armbar yeah in any capacity in the
history of the world if you're getting
choked you can you you could probably do
it yes now if he's he's going out and
yeah he held it and he could have killed
him yeah that you could but armor no
yeah maybe it's a incompetent judge he's
like yeah he's gonna break his arm and
kill him right because that's [__]
stupid right you know that and it's
enraging me right yeah but you never
know no because that's how I know you
barely done anything no no if you break
your elbow and then there's a blood clot
who goes boom right into your [__]
brain aneurysm that's what I would I'd
be a bad lawyer your honor your honor
sure it's his arm he could have broken
the arm and then climbed up to the neck
yeah maybe with the guillotine or rare
naked joke and they hold on to it you
could kill somebody yeah you have to
hold it for a hot second well you can
anybody gets around your neck you can
die quick yeah it's pretty easy to break
your neck it's not easy it's not it's
not easy
they're cracks when you come out of this
way and jump in like that easy necks are
hard to [__] break yeah but you can
you know the movies no you can [__]
that bad you can [__] somebody's neck up
bad
tough
it's not if you're no not if you're who
you can get yourself [__] up you can
break somebody's neck it'd be tough it'd
be really tough well you can do serious
damage to somebody's neck let's put it
that way I mean I've did enough Jiu
Jitsu where my [__] I was like this
for the next [__] it'll be your next
one three months yeah you're sure right
you can expect you can you can [__] I've
been I did for 15 years I'm never see
anybody's neck so [__] up where they
thought they were gonna die well you can
definitely get killed quickly though if
you if you I mean if you choke somebody
no it wouldn't be quick at all no no
you'd have to hold it for over four
minutes Brian
you think so yeah
no I know so yeah over four minutes yeah
took actually kill a human being in a
guillotine yeah it'd take a hot second
because a they'd have to go out right
yeah you could have caused major injury
with the right Guillotine joke major
injury in a short period of time I
believe be tough and I'll tell you
something else in the court of law that
would hold up that would hold up because
you literally cut off their oxygen and
they don't know Jiu Jitsu yeah but yeah
yeah I mean that's what I'm saying
yeah you could use a defense if it's a
guillotine or rear naked joke neck
cracks where you're like there are those
things where you've got somebody here
and your body's on their top of their
head and you're pulling up that way you
can [__] break somebody's neck like
that be toughby yeah I've been some
horrible neck drinks what happened you
know what happened yeah but you have a
very nice neck Bubba and yeah I've seen
I literally grow up nothing but you were
rolling with guys who were you know just
as strong with that but just as strong
as I am if not stronger all of them
right and we all got like you can [__]
somebody's neck up with Jiu Jitsu if
anything oh for sure yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying but yeah but in general
you're not going to damage somebody's
neck
yeah like just give him a guilty no
overall no the odds are yeah and stuff
like that even if he didn't tap a few
holes for a long time you kill him yeah
so that would be I think in a court of
law putting something in a guillotine
would be considered a an assault with a
deadly weapon like in a way you're
trying to kill somebody you could win
that argument where I was on I don't
know my life was in danger because he's
choking me yeah unconscious yeah yeah
they held the joke yeah arm bar no neck
choke yes you could make the defense I
assume you could I think so yeah
how would I know if after I pass out he
he lets me go I don't need to continue
holding the choke and kill me exactly
that's why I stabbed him in the wiener
and also we've seen referees that don't
bad referees that don't stop chokes that
last for a long time and everyone's word
they're gonna die yeah you see that with
what's actually worse is [__] uh uh
ankle walks with their their knee gets
[__] like Paul Harris and stuff those
are bad to you dick
um so
what's that is that Dookie bath water
bath water there's some like clothing
where it looks like it's with blood or
throw up or something like that his mom
before you read the story so this is
Aaron Carter's mother shoots graphic
photos from the scene of his death the
mom's saying that he he had some like
you know he's a drug addict and he
didn't he owed the drug addict or the
drug dealer money and she thinks he was
murdered yeah so she wants an
investigation because they didn't do
autopsy or nothing they're just like yep
suicide and she's like hold up a lot of
people were trying to kill myself so
they did the autopsy the results aren't
in yet but they haven't done like an
investigation of a possible crime right
because they think he just died from a
overdose but his mom shared these
pictures I'm not sure if I'll show this
is it possible to say that they
why is the water like that it's all this
is weird right so there's like a I don't
know the pictures are not a big deal but
so after his mom wanted them to do a
full investigation on potentially a
crime happening uh his fiancee as well
she said a lot of stuff that she saw was
not something that he would normally do
okay I I just have one thing so over the
next few days there were according to
her numerous departures from his normal
pattern of behavior he apparently made a
trip to Walmart disgusting uh which was
very unusual since he didn't like
running errands because of it because of
his anxiety he didn't he didn't use his
cell phone at all in the last 24 hours
before he died that's something that
sounds like some something somebody
would do before they commit suicide it
was later found in his car what Martin
says this doesn't make sense considered
he always carried it with him he had to
leave yourself on your card it is weird
shelter claims he almost took showers
instead of baths yet he was found in the
bathroom he apparently always locked the
door when you went to the bathroom yet
the bathroom door was found unlocked she
also to understand how his dog was shut
in there with him the entire time
between when he died when he was found
he didn't use the bathroom all together
she feels there's enough questions yeah
there's some questions I think it's
worthy of doing it it sounds like it
sounds like classic behavior of somebody
else suicidal yeah on the edge but also
um I hate to say this but like there
probably was an investigation like when
those detectives come in they see a lot
of stuff and they they can they like if
they can put together a lot of stuff if
they thought there was a murder scene
here they they I trust me people would
have been in there they that might my
guess is they saw a lot of things in
there that said this kid killed himself
yeah so he also had a history of this
yeah I mean she called in like a welfare
check so it's following the calls for an
investigation from Aaron Carter's mom
Please Release the statement saying the
autopsy results were still pending but
to the to that point no evidence a foul
play had been discovered Martin
previously said no water was found in
Carter's lungs which is inconsistent
with drowning and pill bottles
reportedly discovered near the bathtub
he was found in the investigation will
continue yep so I don't know I mean if
I'm the family I want all Stones
unturned I'm with them it's like can we
just at least look yeah and I got to
bring him back I was reading about this
too like I guess a lot of people that
have experienced something like this a
suicide or whatever they always want to
deny yeah see if something else happened
because it's too tough for them to
accept yeah I get it I'm with the mom
you guys talked about this already uh
Chris Rock and Will Smith do you have
the Jada Pinkett Smith comments on it I
didn't get her comments but I heard that
look it up look it up JP Smith comments
on uh Larry can you go can you here it
is uh can you go back up for a second
yeah I had it so what is the the title
is this go up please oh so uh what why
Will Smith did not watch Chris Rock's
quote unquote distasteful Netflix comedy
special days go up
said cheating rumors Will's embarrassing
her by what Chris said about him and his
family and his Netflix special he didn't
watch it but he had people tell him what
Chris said
so Will and Jada have been I've seen
comments on it and Jada was like uh
basically saying Chris Rock's obsessed
with her and will oh so I had that one
yeah so it's like no no his husband
slapped them in public and one of the
biggest biggest shows yeah of that year
yeah would you and he's just supposed to
literally take it on the chin not do
anything and do that you guys take no
accountability I mean you didn't
encourage your husband to slap him at
the time yeah you didn't cause all this
horrible trauma for will in order for
him to build in this rage in order to
slap [__] Chris Rock but also [__]
another dude in Hawaii and rub it in his
face take some goddamn accountability
Propecia or not over the [__] she is
a [__] apparently that rumor or that
that statement came from an Insider that
knows the situation saying that uh Chris
was always obsessed with Jada Pinkett
well can I see the what is the quote
that's it no it's just an Insider said
that uh Chris has always been not
obsessed like he's in love with her but
obsessed with like you know just I think
what what Chris Rock did was appropriate
so real quick I guess apparently Jada
didn't want uh Chris to attend an Oscars
because Will Smith wasn't nominated for
an Oscar for that concussion movie so
since you know things like that that
would happen so you know Chris just did
not like her apparently I don't know
that's yeah but that's such [__]
it's like also that none of that has
anything to do with the fact that he
still got up and slapped him in the face
and he didn't even say anything bad so
this is uh uh years ago his wife said I
should quit the Oscars I shouldn't host
because her man didn't get nominated for
concussion and then he gives me a
[__] concussion
while presenting the year's ceremony he
made a joke uh
uh not rock claims he made this joke in
response opinions request that's how it
is she starts it I finish it okay that's
what the [__] happened nobody's picking
on her she started this [__]
and to be honest she she seems like
someone that's like
but yeah it seems like it
anyway
I really for Will Smith my whole life
now I watch emancipation just see him
get one
that's the greatest
I mean he had great jokes about it
wake up hell yeah dude why is that on
oh you would know my man
huh
I don't know is that when you're
supposed to come leave your house to
come to the show with Bert do you think
it's really weird that's when the rock
slide happened I don't know
what else you got Jed
um
Jada and will can't say [__] they just
got to eat this yeah You Gotta Eat It
You Gotta Eat It
Chris Rock did for how over a year he's
been taking all this abuse like say
something say something I will I will
you got two to my special that's how
this goes right and I heard that
somewhere at one of their friends it
might have been Donna Rawlings I saw
something where like this this is
actually going to be the thing that
happens where they can get back together
and be friends because they both had
their yeah you went it's like the slap
fight you went now will went yeah Chris
went both he got slapped one literally
got slapped the other guy slapped with
jokes oh now we move on here I'll become
friends I bet you they do a movie
together here's my question I I think
you're right but here's my question
um if Will doesn't it's like then you
see if Will doesn't what my thing is
that that will spent a lot of his entire
career pretending to be perfect
trying to be which he's dancing there
was and I'm a fan I'm still and I think
he had a moment yeah okay forgive you
try it I would count yes you know what I
mean you know I counter right hope he
doesn't kill you if he gets you in an
arm bar
how stupid I'm stupid
kill somebody put him an arm bar oh
really I didn't say [__] face I didn't
say that don't call me wait the point is
that oh really the thing about my
question is does Doug Will Smith
what is he like after this because like
this is amazing
horribly like you know what I mean like
like he may never be the same in some
ways unless he like he's been trying to
be perfect his whole life he's got to
kind of like the thing about Chris Rock
is Chris Rock is just open he's honest
yeah doing what he does but Will Smith
has been living in a Faberge Eggman and
so that [__] got shattered I really want
to know what it's hard for him to get
out of his head now
is it or am I wrong I don't I don't know
it depends how well how much of social
media will pays attention to right and
then you know wherever he walks people
like I love you so it doesn't matter he
doesn't know like but you know how that
is you know I get hate and it still gets
to you and I you go on the street and
everyone's like I love you but still
I love you in person can get taken away
really fast when you jump in your car
and you see [__] you and you're like oh
man well yeah it hurts more to see it in
writing than here than well but people
love you a little bit of a difference
with you
anybody who knows you loves you do you
think everybody loves will though too no
am I an alley cat version Wilson you
know what I'm saying in a way what will
did is they gave him a reason you
understand like will knows he [__] up
will knows that that is part of who he
really is I'm not saying he's not a good
guy but the last judgment yeah the
angels of his lesser nature when you're
trying to be perfect your whole [__]
life exhausting it's like like Tiger
Woods had to be perfect his whole life
in every way perfect swing disciplined
as [__] guess what man he [__] had a
little outline every human being if
you're trying bro you got a lot I'm
coming after him again today his old
girlfriend who who's a tiger's old
girlfriend's coming sure yeah but you
know like you you know he was playing
around a lot the guy [__] he [__] it
was the one hour oh really he's like let
me get it also this is my thing with
that like this thing with the wife and
all the the golf club and her [__] up
the car yeah she found out he cheated on
her to get that but when people were
like what Tiger Woods hold on you're
talking about the best golfer of all
time like more than one girl oh my God
of all time and I guess what I got news
for and arm bar is not going to kill you
you know what I'm saying you know stupid
you gotta be well well you you don't see
you don't you don't see what he deals
with
uh will Tiger Woods oh I know you don't
know when you see a guy like Derek Jeter
Tiger Woods
LeBron James Mike Tyson you don't know
you have no idea into this Adam Levine
yeah what kind of female attention
they get
and also what those girls look like
heavy lies the crown you have no idea I
get it and I mean
constantly no we don't have an idea no
idea I've seen it though I have a glance
I've looked behind the curve I've been
in proximity yeah of that and watched
like my buddy sat with Mike Tyson 10
years ago 15 years ago sat with him in
Vegas probably 20 years ago right no it
was about 15. out of his career no not
the height of his car right well I hear
a hangout I hear O.J Simpson goes in a
bar it is snow bunny Central I bet it is
like just white girls are like okay now
to this right now yeah he lives in Vegas
in Florida no doubt you don't have my OJ
bit and like oh you should he's a great
dude I'm like look really like yeah and
they're like in the girls man this guy
has more chicks anybody you know I'm
like O.J Simpson yeah even OJ kill the
girl that's that's they want to be close
to the boogeyman yeah
uh seriously Boogeyman lays it down
O.J Simpson was always getting all the
tales oh so I know that from another
Hollywood star yes before he went away
yeah I mean it was like it was it's not
like out of control yeah I know yeah
yeah more than anybody yeah soji Simpson
Marcus Allen the Jews this black amazing
athletes take it easy man what do you
have an erection
those black athletes oh man can you
imagine just all the white girls who
aren't supposed to can you imagine just
have that big chocolate dick in your
mouth what well no it's more the white
girls in in La who are now actresses and
they both their whole life they haven't
been allowed to they're from Kentucky
and then you're they're little funds
they're just looking for a big black
dick well or it's just naughty yeah it
is naughty
hot naughty
why are we both rock hard now
what else catching
point is Chris Rock should Chris rocket
and will just needs to take on the chin
and then full circle what's he do what
do you what would you no will what would
you advise him to do come out like he
should tweet or just do a video by
that's what I get this is how it goes I
expect this I I would do a video you
should go I love the special I I deserve
all this Chris great job I get it man
I'm gonna shoot you a text after this
yeah I would shoot myself watching it
and just being like you don't need to do
all that just be like very good you saw
it I deserve it good job man now you
know why like I'd rather you slap me
than do another joke please don't do
another joke it hurts my feet that's so
good that's why that's it me too hey
Chris can you just slap me so I don't
have to go through this again right
that's what I do there you go yeah now
what um here's the problem with that
what's the problem with that dude you
got to give up your wine for a night
there you go change you had to know Jada
Pinkett Smith I don't think it's gonna
would allow that I'm really curious to
see if he does that yeah she might be
the Mastermind she doesn't want him
doing that no I guarantee it she's like
don't be no [__] you ain't no freshers
[__]
there you go right ain't no Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air you don't I haven't seen him
do anything I he if he hasn't done it by
now I don't think he's going to do that
he needs to do it like now don't don't
wait with it but like that apology did
on video which was like it was like he's
a hostage oh so bad you're like oh come
on well this isn't from the heart
somebody wrote this for you
he's got to be like hey he got me and I
deserved it yeah hey Chris please stop
I'd rather you stop the problem is Chris
brought his wife into it again
I shouldn't say again because he didn't
really bring his wife into it no she's
the one it sounds like she's the she's
the one that's poking pride in here yeah
hopefully Crystal ain't giving a Harmon
kill him
[Music]
that'd be tragic right all I'm saying is
guilty to really mess up his neck yeah
well you see it all the time what else
realities are dangerous he's stupid no
guilty are you a little stupid right hey
a little bit with all certain stuff
Guillotine need a little stupid
Guillotine huh Guillotine huh a little
stupid dangerous for your neck stupid no
I'm not hopefully dude hopefully you
don't get looked either that'd be
[__] terrible at Guillotine or neck
crank I know you imagine [__] kill
her man you could be saying that all the
time all the time we see it all the time
in sports yeah awesome you can hurt
somebody very badly very bad dude kill
him better watch out yeah I'm with you
dude no you're not
and all I said about the arm bar was
that you said he I said you said I said
no because when you're stuck like that
it's like that's Jujitsu and I'm Gonna
Save myself and you stab him no because
he's got me in a position and he could
kill me well
right now I'm not I'm in trouble and
there could be a transition now you
[__] up man
there's a transition dude that's all I'm
saying
what's the word Andy uh stump you just
called you what bag of dicks uh now uh
[__] back
he called the guy a cockpack
yes demons [__] bags and Five Alarm
[__]
and this Five Alarm [__]
I think especially with the drugs and
the steroid failures and those oh wait I
didn't see that shoot let's see I think
especially with the drugs and the
steroid failures and those types of
things I think when you have those
things it's hard to call you the
greatest of all time do you see a little
salty right of John there's also a thing
where you know his reaction to when John
got the submission the give the
guillotine by the way the space he was
just like I hope Sarah Khan does he did
he die did serial Clan die because what
guilty was okay we never people were
giving Daniel Cormier a hard time
because Daniel core was like
he was like this on the reaction you
know normally they're like oh oh maybe
because he's expecting more that's what
did him to do some kind of Defense he no
he's still like he didn't see the Finish
happening he's like did he even have his
arm all the way through that's what he
said they said when he saw the other
angles again he was fine he's like
people gave him a hard time that's my
question um and I love Daniel Cormier
kids of course but if John isn't The
Goat Who is the goat he probably thinks
khabibas because that's his boy he's
wrong in every capacity but yeah they'd
be very wrong but also Francis since
Francis was the you know the heavyweight
champion but he left the belt so Francis
is definitely not the goat I mean no not
even close of the heavyweight division
definitely not I know enough times he
lost John's never lost a heavy weight
never lost that light heavyweight it
just doesn't make any sense uh I will
say that Francis like Stipe is a D1
wrestler and his wrestling was no good
against Francis so whose was it
um Steve age wrestling again Stephen
took practice down you yeah but he still
got knocked out like like Stipe was able
France was able to initialize that
wrestling no he wasn't what are you
talking about
he you're saying with the the the second
time they fought yeah the first time he
had taken down oh yeah yeah the second
time we should stay on the ground but he
was able to kind of neutralize that
wrestling Steven really didn't wrestle
right but if John can Francis what does
I think John takes Francis right the
[__] down yeah right yeah dude yeah he
ain't he ain't sprawling on any double
legs
right that's easy fight for him yeah
easy part easy so if he's not goes just
like so you can't say you can't say no
the argument's over I won't even
entertain it right yeah there's no
argument
and a volcanovski Beat mock Jeff there's
a you could there's that you call him
the girl but outside that he didn't so
there's no argument yeah
why do you keep going on Andy stuff oh
no because you guys mentioned Annie
something I saw like uh I guess he
opened up a Black Rifle coffee shop
the whole block is it yeah we do a thing
called tactical [__] which is great
yeah he's great
yeah
yeah there's no conversation when it
comes to John now no
so I saw this article I guess there was
a an investigation by Sheriff's civilian
oversight commission and apparently
there are like
half a dozen really high the gangster
level people in the sheriff's department
it's been known for a while yeah
I forget what they call themselves so
wait so there was it there were gangs
there were gang members who who no they
they're essentially gang members and
Clicks in the LA Sheriff's department
and they do like crazy [__] the one I
heard was the executioners so they it's
a it's a group of guys high up in the
police force and they go out and they're
basically a gang and they're you know
they're running [__] and they're they do
stuff just like real gang members like
they [__] with people in the public and
all that stuff really yeah there's it's
like a known thing and they're trying to
get rid of them they're strange
yeah what world you lived in dude what
like that the that the police force the
Sheriff's Office of Los Angeles has any
type of accounts they have a long
standing record with this oh I don't I'm
this first time I've ever oh no even
when they had the the rights and stuff
I've heard about yeah well I remember
the Rampart Division and stuff like that
but this is uh
like I I'm still kind of confused so
they are they they enforce the law but
they do what they are also they run
within the department the gang
membership routinely seeks out violent
encounters with the public the
investigation reports as well as the
internal command and control structure
of uh Los Angeles sheriff's department
Sheriff Department Of The Gangs
undermine supervision destroy public
trust discriminatory disruptive and act
contrary to a professional policing so I
have a thought on perhaps the most alarm
in the investigation reveals that in
recent years tattooed W gang members
that's what I've seen have risen to the
highest levels uh the of Department
leadership calls out the recent former
Sheriff Alex who he just lost yeah lost
his 2022 re-election bid for betraying
promise of Reform by installing gang
members as his right-hand men uh at
minimum tolerated if not rewarded W
gangs
uh the new investigation describes a
deputy gang culture that is deeply
embedded within the Los Angeles Sheriff
Department calling it cancer that must
be exercised the count of the [__] the
county body that that Watchdogs LASD
um 80 Witnesses
dispositions depositions hold on this is
what I this is my feeling this is what
they do is this groups of people in the
sheriff's department that are
responsible for combating gang activity
and are they a gang themselves and they
I mean that you know what I'm saying uh
how who wrote this how skewed is this
like the so like these guys are tough
they get into clicks they fight gangs
they do some crazy [__] yeah is it is it
is it a good gang find a bad game like
are they shooting innocent people and
shaking down innocent people I don't
think so chin and I don't agree you had
that on this I don't know it feels like
these guys are and here's why things are
like Training Day guys yeah and I want
in these guys are the guys who are like
oh I just want to play games well [__]
I'll be your Ethan Hawke damn I don't
know you like to get wet Brian they
create rituals that valorize violence
yeah but they also get into gang [__]
they also get into gun fights with guys
this includes holding shooting parties
to celebrate a member deputies who
opened fire and suspects as well as
authorizing deputies who have shot a
Community member to add embellishments
to their common gang tattoos I don't
know I got skeptical hippo eyes here I
really do I think if you talk together
if you talk to Los Angeles Sheriff guys
they might be like dude
there's so much more to that story but
I'm sure there's yeah because they're in
on it right I'm sure there's officers
that do stuff like Shake people down
always happen I'm saying getting money
and all that stuff and whatever yeah
maybe there's just a fuel in there click
also known as a gang well well if
there's a really bad gang area right
you're dealing with the Crips or whoever
it is sure
you got some rough dudes fighting those
guys those guys go into that war zone
knowing they might be killed or they
probably grew up there yeah instead of
entering the Crips they entered the LAPD
yeah speaking of Crips uh Skip Bayless
if the article says Skip Bayless
suggests NBA people are asking him if
John [__] is a a Crips gang member why
is he asked that but this is what uh
Skip Bayless said on this show he said
this skip Billy's who's been around
basketball and genre so we should talk
say something genre yeah here's the
thing flash a gun at a Denver nightclub
they said nightclub now I retweeted this
listen it's not a nightclub Shotgun
Willies which is an Infamous strip club
it's the best strip club in all of them
and I've been there multiple times and
did not show my gun all right take it I
mean yeah there were two guns right yeah
no no they let me pass yeah right yeah
yep so John rat went there he's waving
you're just there to kind of like see
friends and the guns are there I'm
always carrying right yeah well there's
the Bazooka below the waist or the two
[__] nine millimeters that's right
right all right so I'm carrying all
times the point yeah but so John rant he
grew up with a good family like he's not
very thuggish he's not you know this
this badass but he's been waving a gun
pulled a gun out on some teenagers on on
the team bus like he's doing all this
crazy [__] so this is why uh Skip
Bayless goes I've been called around the
league to people I've known forever
talking about Morant because I was so
shocked by the IG live how Brazen it was
and I've had several people say to me
well time out are you sure you guys on
TBR are giving them a pass here like
you're not that they're asking me are
you sure he's not that like that's just
who he is that is he's about that life
which would be weird because he didn't
grow up in that life and remember he's
throwing up the [__] sign I've seen him
throw it up two or three times I
probably missed some other times Bayless
says uh what does that mean does that
mean he wants to associate with the
Crips or is he initiated by the Crips or
he has this big dream of being a [__]
hey dude you're one of the best players
in the NBA what are you doing I don't
know I'm just throwing this out that
that are we missing the boat here and
that's just who he's been from the start
and we keep saying no you're just
associated with the wrong people when
he's actually part of the world then he
goes on to say and I and I could have
excused all that behavior with the gun
and everything but then he threw
somebody in an arm bar right there and
killed him and killed him he killed him
that's where and then the other guy then
the other guy he put in a guillotine
really messed up his neck and the guy's
in rehab so that's why that's where he
drew the line that's right drove one
it is interesting I don't know why uh
John Moran's doing that he's like top oh
so John Moran of course and here's my
thing if you have that money just what
are you doing just higher security I
have one's badass security guy you don't
have to worry about it yeah it's not and
work on your armbar to kill people yeah
use chujitsu yeah watch out for a knife
yeah but kill with your arm bar yeah
I'll show you but no but that that
sounds like a guy that wants to say like
he's street but he's really not like
come on IG live yes come on yeah here's
the thing most gangsters are they're not
gonna do that no no he's gonna shoot you
yeah
because that's where you're from
uh all right so I'll kill Brian right
now with an alarm right now and you go
no oh I carry a small knife what's this
this is pretty crazy this is in
Louisiana Venice Louisiana this is a
fishing charter boat and there was like
a Shark Feeding Frenzy I've never seen
anything like this before watch this
what kind of sharks are they I don't
know but are they black dip but look at
how many
the tip I'll jump right in the middle I
don't know if you will weiner first in
the middle and I will arm bar every
shark and kill them all that's a real
frenzy that's a that's it there's
sardines or something in the pool yeah
in the water there yeah don't call it a
pool Brennan
I mean they're chopped that looks insane
right but also get your reels into the
[__] water and catch some shards
you guys are chopping that up
everywhere my white you ever have like
like
my wife like I was [__] driving and
she got two tacos I don't know if you'll
appreciate this but she's like eating
sugar because like like people are have
feeding frenzies oh and she's eating
these tacos because she hadn't eaten and
she's doing this deep throwing them
she's going
this is so good I'm like oh yeah yeah
how is it so good how is this so good it
drives me nuts
oh see that God this is good I'm like
my step mom would do that whenever
there's a hot meal
my stepmom without a doubt every time
she comes to visit they stay with us my
dad'll cook his meatballs or whatever
as soon as you I just put my Fork down
I'll see you guys later
I'll give you a couple no no no don't
keep doing it it is triggering then she
goes she kept doing it and finally she's
like this she was I can't believe I ate
this whole thing I can't the sauce
then do you want to try some where was
it from Taco Bell or something Del Taco
no it was this place oh and then she
used my credit card and and I'm like you
lost my wallet you lost my I freaked out
all day I was a dick yeah you hit her he
[__] took no no no you [__] hitter
dude no dude because she would hit me
back and [__] me up not if you put her
arm bar you're not doing that because
her feet are like she has long feet her
feet are like hands it's like fighting a
chimp oh interesting yeah
freaking out
I put my wallet down there oh you made a
mistake yeah she sent me a video she's
like here's your wallet dumbass you're
an [__] yeah it's like I am it is
frustrating though I get it my bad but
if you did do it if you did this is how
I would act yeah for the future so you
know if you do lose the wall this is how
I act now you know because it's such a
nightmare if you lose your wallet
nightmare yeah
here's a quick one there was a guy that
won a two billion whatever
he bought a 25 million dollar home 25.5
million home I think this is in a
where was this yeah the hills well one
two point four billion dollars yeah and
no one knows his identity because he I
didn't know you could do that I thought
you had to do that no now you're good
scroll down to him because he got
hold on uh so he snagged a 13 000 square
foot home in the hills of La uh coming
just one month after claiming his
one-time payment of a base 997 million
dollars basically one billion dollars
before taxes
let me say that 25 million dollar home
I don't know if they showed up just this
one here no no no it's not if you have a
billion dollars oh yes 900 oh I'm sorry
900. that's nothing [__] no yeah he
could have went bigger but I'm sure they
could track down who this which they
shouldn't but I'm sure they can now
because they know which home he bought
so who gives a [__] no you can put homes
in uh trust and stuff they can't figure
that out to be smart if you're the smart
businessman to put in a different trust
that's pretty cool I bet they did that's
badass though that's my home
20 but 25 million if you're for a home
purchase after you want to build I get
it billions of crazy chin that's like
you leasing an apartment would you buy a
25 million dollar home absolutely
property right Brandon Brandon whatever
uh 25 yeah I'd buy a 10 million dollars
if you gave me a billion yeah I'm
probably spend 100 million on the house
yeah or multiple houses yeah no I can
put all multiple I guess 25 million home
I would too 100 billion dollars yeah I
would expect you to do the same yeah if
you had a billion I'm like hey are you
in my beak wet otherwise I'm gonna start
chatting I'd be chatting or otherwise
daddy's gonna start chatting I don't
know what's going to take for you I
gotta start going on Reddit daddy in a
chat yeah I'm gonna go on red and start
chatting that's what I would do I'd be
like Hey listen
we can play ball
I don't want to do that I said my beak
is so drunk I feel chat and you know who
else is beaks are drying my friends on
Reddit yeah got it you gotta I'm gonna
start chatting we're thirsty we're
thirsty thirsty for new a billion
dollars and I can't get 10 million dude
that's our deal if either of us hit the
big time like that you get a billion you
have to that minimum 20 million goes to
your buddy got it right 20 million we've
been we've been through a lot of [__]
together yeah 20 mil well this this week
is dry I just want a house and when my
Beats dry I talk dude I have to it's the
only way I can get hydrated I know but
I'll wait your Beats just give me a
second I gotta cast the chat no no no no
no what the [__] you put them both on it
hooked me up with a [__] corporate
gig they paid me 24 Grand back and left
my beak alone he goes he goes you might
want to wet my beak a little bit yeah I
think it's for you don't want to [__]
hook this up I'm 240 000 I was like that
was everything to me I was like holy
[__] [__] what the guy's Beacon I
gotta wait your big 24 grand for one
show I was like I can't wait your
buddies
because
the peak gets dry I gave him 3 500 bucks
but whatever you think so I would have
maybe I did get I'm also a dumbass with
money yeah so Georgie showed me this I
guess we're uh
what's up Casper's uh they think
Casper's actually uh has something wrong
with this oh so this particular so he
doesn't uh he doesn't think I don't care
look at them tits I know that's all I
saw too God damn it bro you know how I
know you're gay oh that alligator
I didn't notice her tits so she's
swimming underneath an alligator a giant
alligator that's that's Casper though I
don't care what his [__] name is
what's her name her name is Gabby now
she's actually very cute
oh she has a lot of uh Exotica let's see
those beaks are dry
things let the beets let the birds wet
them beaks on your she's pretty
is she yeah that's uh that's that's a
big old python that's yup she likes a
pipe I'd like to see him ten points you
know what python that is kind of python
is that ball if I can get into it you're
gonna say bald and I that's a ball you
were gonna say ball I wanna see that
snake go all over that baldy right those
are that is that is a
she's cool yeah she's cool beautiful
young lady yeah anyhow I like her oh boy
there she is with the armadillo I don't
I bet you guys didn't realize how
[__] hairy they are Casper just lets
you uh pick him up huh
they do have some I didn't know this
we'll let you pick him up yeah that's
armadillos baby armadillo
you know what kind of cat that is right
there that's the links nope Sphinx it's
terrible
I don't like how into the animals you
are not the tit that's what drives me
nuts dude you [__] up with the armbar
[__] and now you're like oh dude
check out the alligator his name is
albino he's a mental disease where he
thinks humans are friends
what
dude not everything is tits oh that
bird's beak is super dry that's that's a
dry beak right there
that's a dry Peak
yeah hell yeah well Brendan we did it
again guys if you like comedy I'm
telling you right now this weekend we
still have tickets left at Stony Hall
March 11th New York New Year tickets why
are there still tickets left yeah right
it's your hometown Levity Live the next
weekend March 16th go back to New York
Sunny Hall let's go March 11th that's
that's disappointing for New York not to
sell out for you yeah and then oh you're
working on my birthday weird because
I'll be in Austin Texas are you doing it
with Joe Rogan Eddie Broughton a special
guest for cowboy for a regular
professional guest yeah you didn't
replace dude [__] you guys man yeah man
[__] you damn it [__] you uh was it nut
bag is that was it nut bag come back
TalkBack TalkBack [__] bags funny [__]
bag come back
well my Beats can be super dry in
Oklahoma City Oklahoma City this
Thursday Friday Saturday bricks down
Comedy Club then Tacoma Washington is
March 23rd through 25th like I said the
uh March 18th day my birthday that
Saturday a we have a fight campaign on
JRE you can watch it live on Jerry's
YouTube but it will be uh Joe Rogan
Eddie Bravo myself a special guest for
the Leon Edwards Usman fight and that is
March 18th my birthday turned 40 Daddy
can I get a prediction on that fight my
beak's wet uh Usman beats the [__] out
of him uh Atlanta Georgia April 13th
through the 15th and La Jolla just went
on sale La Jolla Comedy Store June 2nd
through the 4th and then the Europe tour
it's happening uh your boys going to
Europe Belfast Glasgow Manchester London
Cardiff and Dublin that's June 17th
through the through the 25th I'll be all
over you know what and my biggest dream
that's perfect because I'm I'm in Israel
doing what why are they letting you in
Israel family trip to Israel yeah who's
we got to figure that out I think I'm
gone then anyway so we'll just take that
week off
we'll bank one yeah or we can just take
it off it's the summer thank you be good
what's that I think banking would be
good we'll Bank some yeah you know what
you can do is Bank these nuts in your
mouth I can't believe podcast with me
when I'm in green you want to [__] me in
the butt all right
Oklahoma City see this weekend